finally get the chance to start for an
NBA team five and a half to one sister
Nova ratio Steph Curry lays read at home
and Tyler Zeller in battle Zeller comes
in first Hollis Jefferson had three
turnovers already through six minutes
and there's curry right on cue
cousin walls of questions and that's
what it is always a lot of questions
very beautiful jump into the passing
lane stepping right down the lane lay it
up and an x-up fadeaway curry got the
deflected rebound Nick Young catching
two three and x-ray
she was also content to take couple
goals
[Applause]
we're free bound for curry please
got something tonight and snapped the
rebound the run and the triple this
Chevelle Magritte degree just runs right
in front of the defender Gatsby now you
see how quickly the Nets want to shoot
the ball quickly and it young with
another three guards
he's knowing that I'll tell you what
he's setting up this Kabongo knees broke
right there well it's Stefan curry
though three-point play possibility
curry with another steal that's a third
of the night for him a little behind the
back was not the one you usually make
see highs using that screen Springs and
open what Steph here this mesmerizes
levert and gets him well they won that
championship in 2015 to that
sorry vile this is a circus shot any
pieces there best shooter ass be running
gas be floating at hold on that for six
so far tonight
that's floppy there but came out of it
this top zaza run over to bari Carol to
make sure the horse didn't lose
possession and shoot it
[Music]
bounce pass on a backdoor cut
down
Ares Finnegan hold
[Applause]
well he just knows how to create shots
in a variety of ways in a crowd without
a crowd either side of the rim knows how
to use the